je suis désolé pour la violence de ce
titre mais c'est vrai quoi je suis pas
votre ami je suis pas ton ami il faut
qu'on en parle régulièrement quand je
m'exprime sur un sujet je reçois des
messages hors patois cyrus patois et
m'ont alors il ya une partie de ces
messages qui sont humoristiques inserts
en référence à un événement
footballistique mythique celui ci fait
un déchirement mais il ya une grosse
partie de ces messages qui sont très
premier degré et qui sont très sérieux
et quand je les reçois je ressente de
choses je suis à la fois triste parce
que je sais que je vous ai déçu et s'est
jamais agréable de décevoir quelques uns
même si j'ai juste donné mon opinion
voilà je suis un peu triste de vous
avoir déçu et l'autre partie de ce que
je ressens c'est que ben je trouve ça
drôle parce que je me dis ouah vous avez
pu projeter tellement de choses sur moi
pour ensuite me dire ça parce que j'ai
juste donné mon avis et ce décalage me
fait rire alors pourquoi ces gens sont
déçus qu'est-ce qu'ils ont projeté sur
moi et est ce que ce qu'ils ont projeté
sur moi vous êtes actuellement en train
de le faire les amis et ce mot et ô
combien important pour la suite de la
vidéo
aujourd'hui on a parlé de relations par
asocial générique c'est vous et pas de
générique alors une relation parent
social c'est quoi c'est une relation que
vous formez avec une personne que vous
ne connaissez pas en consommant du
contenu sur cette personne
on s'en rend pas forcément compte parce
que ça touche les célébrités mais aussi
les personnages de fiction comme par
exemple mon meilleur pote arrête un raid
oui je parle de toi
il est chiant et donc on dit que c'est
une relation qui est pas asocial parce
que même si vous avez l'impression de
connaître la personne et de l'est mais
elle elle ne vous connaît pas et ne vous
aime pas en tout cas pas de la manière
dont vous voulez mais quoi donc ça
existe depuis que l'humanité se raconte
des histoires et ensuite ça a été un
petit peu amplifié avec le cinéma donc
les stars de dallas les stars de ciné la
télévision et maintenant youtuber et
honnêtement je peux comprendre alors je
prends mon propre exemple puisque voilà
étant donné que je passe beaucoup de
temps avec cette entité et que enfin je
connais tous ses secrets etc
je pense que c'est un exemple que je
maîtrise assez bien ça me paraît logique
du coup de parler de moi et je me rends
compte de tout le contenu que je mets
sur internet que ce soit donc via les
vidéos youtube
mais aussi via les tweets via newsletter
que ça fait un mois que j'ai pas poster
instagram toutes les stories et où tous
les jours
les live tweet chetout bref une personne
qui regarderait tout ce contenu
mais forcément elle a l'impression de me
connaître forcément l'impression de
connaître mes goûts mes opinions toutes
mes mimiques peut-être même ma
garde-robe
ce qui me fait marrer mon humour enfin
bref voilà tout ça est clairement moi
aussi je vis ça à traire des gens que je
kiffe et que je suis sur les réseaux
mais que je connais pas dans la vraie
vie où des gens que je suis et qui ni
mon existence comme par exemple mon
oncle mais je me dis ici j'étais au
coeur d'une communauté avec tous les
lives les installe les tweets les
youtube et tout bas j'aurais vraiment
l'impression de connaître cette personne
et donc d'être son pote et c'est normal
et un sociologue américain qui s'appelle
mark granovetter qui donne quatre
critères relationnel qui selon lui
définissent la proximité dans une
relation le premier c'est l'intimité bon
bah dans notre cas je vous parle de plus
en plus de mon opinion souvent dans mes
titres vous avez vu dernièrement c'est
plus jeu avant je parlais de l'opinion
d'un philosophe maintenant c'est
vraiment voilà sa part d'une réflexion
personnelle
on est dans mon salon c'est mon salon ça
genre c'est mon canapé doux et sur
instagram dans nos délires encore je
parle de mon animal domestique je vous
parle de comment je m'occupe de mes
plantes etc bref il ya une intimité
l'intensité émotionnelle dans notre cas
ça me fait penser à la vidéo sur la
rupture que j'ai sorti il ya quelques
mois qui a été assez intense et genre où
j'étais au bord des larmes plusieurs
fois dans la vidéo en fait c'est très
émouvant pour moi est très fort de la
sortir elle a publié le temps passer bon
là c'est facile c'est le nombre de
vidéos de live etc
tout ça voilà ça fait qu'on passe du
temps ensemble en fait et la réciprocité
de service donc là c'est le fait que moi
je serai comme un dératé
je travaille les week-ends des fois je
fais des nuits blanches et cetera pour
vous sortir des vidéos et vous ce que je
vous demande en retour c'est de me
soutenir en laye qu'en partageant en
vous intéressant aux sponsors quand il y
en a un
bref tout ce genre de choses ces
critères et vont plus ou moins
s'appliquer à certains d'entre vous
évidemment quelqu'un qui est au coeur de
la communauté ne va pas ressentir ça de
la même façon que quelqu'un qui regarde
mes vidéos qui n'est même pas abonné par
exemple d'ailleurs je sais qu'au coeur
de la communauté et aussi des liens
horizontaux qui se font parce qu'il ya
une vraie communauté qui s'est créé avec
les twitch et cetera donc et gens qui
parlent et qui sont créés des groupes et
qui parle du coût sans moi je suis très
curieux de savoir si les interactions
qui les ont les uns avec les autres ont
un impact sur leur perception de la
relation qu'on a eu et moi voilà ça j'ai
pas vu d'étude là dessus parce que c'est
vrai que tout ce que je vous dis là ça a
été vachement documenté mais beaucoup
d'études etc
par exemple un abîme que j'ai lu qui
s'appelle the development of par sochaux
les chips en youtube est en fait le truc
c'est que vu que bah je suis au coeur du
truc ça m'a rien appris entre guillemets
c'est cool parce que ça permet de
prouver des choses mais qui me semble
évidente
donc ils ont théorisé plein truc avec
des arbres des chemins des coefficients
et ses parents va pas trop en parler ça
sert pas à grand chose dans cette vidéo
en revanche on va parler c'est qu'il ya
trois facteurs qui influencent les
relations parent social on a vu quatre
critères relationnel qui définissent la
proximité dans une relation
là c'est trois facteurs qui influencent
la relation parra sociale le premier
c'est le direct dressing c'est à dire le
fait de m'adresser directement à vous
alors j'ai un peu de mal avec les
youtuber les youtube buzz qui disent tu
alors communauté ça a déjà dû m'arriver
parce que parfois c'est plus approprié
mais je sais qu'il y en a qui disent
tout le temps tu es tu
un peu flou ensuite il ya le physique au
groupe irens ces genres toutes les
informations visuelles que vous allez
sortir de cette vidéo donc ça va être
fait par exemple mon style vestimentaire
va ma tête mes mimiques on décore enfin
bref plein de choses en fait où vous
allez vous dire potentiellement à j'aime
bien cyrus il a l'air cool et enfin la
fréquence parce que effectivement si je
sors qu'une vidéo par an va pas y avoir
de relation parent social
en tout cas elle va être dur à
développer alors est ce que les
créateurs et des créatrices ils sont
conscients de ça oui et non on ne fait
pas notre contenu dans un but de
développer une relation parra social
c'est pas le but primaire mais on le
fait dans un but quand même d'être
apprécié de sorte à ce que notre contenu
trouve une résonance enfin tu vois il ya
un peu de ça quand même
on cherche un petit peut être apprécié
notre communauté du coup on va faire des
choses qui malgré nous vont augmenter
cette relation parra sociale et pour la
plupart d'entre nous c'est dans notre
intérêt tant que c'est raisonnable
évidemment la question c'est est-ce que
c'est dans votre intérêt à vous le truc
c'est que vous savez que c'est une
relation parent social
vous savez qu on n'est pas amis enfin
presque
sur twitter j'ai demandé si vous pensiez
que j'étais votre ami vous êtes 14% à
m'avoir dit oui j'ai posé la même
question sur instagram et là vous êtes
45% à m'avoir dit oui ce qui est assez
révélateur de la proximité qu'on a sur
ce réseau vous pouvez me suivre dessus
si vous êtes cool seulement si vous êtes
cool et j'ai reçu ce dm que j'ai trouvé
parfait parce qu ils pointent notamment
du doigt ceux dont je vous parle ce
indemme qui dit c'est fou parce que j'ai
mis oui par réflexe mais en fait c'est
non mais c'est comme si mon cerveau tu
avais automatiquement considéré comme un
proche
alors qu'on se connaît pas la raison ce
que si on se connaissait j'aurais dit
que t'avais s'écrit avec un ps en fait
vous savez de manière très logique que
c'est réciproque
et pourtant quelques parents vous et je
veux dire même quelques parents nous
puisque je le vis exactement la même
façon quand je suis de l'autre côté de
la barrière
quelques parents nous on oublie ce truc
qu'on sait est un thème philosophique
pour ça qu'ils assez récents qui a été
inventé en 2008 par tamar gender qui est
prof de philosophie psychologie et
sciences cognitives à l'université de
yale et ce terme c e n'est un oeil vif
c'est un belief donc une croyance un
petit peu automatique et qui va à
l'encontre des croyances que l'on a de
manière logique et raisonné par exemple
renvoie un balcon avec le sol envers
notre croyance résonnait notre belief
c'est de croire que bah c'est solide ça
tient bien il ya plein de gens qui vont
dessus tous les jours ça a été construit
pour et a aucun problème
par contre au niveau du l ihf ça va pas
du tout on est un peu en stress on a
peur que ça se casse à tout moment et
bien ici notre alif nous pousse à penser
qu'on est potes et c'est intéressant
parce que les effets d'une relation
parra sociales sont en fait assez
similaires parfois à ceux d'une relation
sociale et une étude de jl d'eric qui
montrent que les relations parent social
pas faire tampon contre la perte
d'estimé de soi et le rejet social
un peu comme si on allait trouver notre
soutien émotionnel pas seulement dans
nos vrais amis mais aussi dans nos
relations parent social est aussi une
étude de gardeur à noël 2008 qui
montrent que lorsqu'on est exposé à une
photo dans nos personnages favoris même
un personnage de fiction
eh ben on a un boost de performance dans
nos tâches cognitives comme on pourrait
avoir la présence d'un règne donc à une
frontière un peu floue parfois qui fait
que quand on se croise parfois c'est
chelou quoi alors bon en ce moment ça
arrive pas trop déjà parce que je sors
très peu de chez moi et quand je sors je
suis masqué etc mais en temps normal
voilà
ça arrive très régulièrement enfin genre
à peu près tous les jours les trois
quarts du temps ça se passe très bien
j'ai pas de soucis vous êtes respectueux
l'échangé bref tout est cool mais ça que
parfois il ya ce truc où vous me
connaissez de ouf
et moi je vous connais pas du tout genre
par exemple quelqu'un pourrait venir me
voir aime faire you make
j'espère faire mieux ta rupture en fait
c'est hyper chez vous parce que je sais
effectivement que vous en avez parler tu
vas dans une vidéo il ya cinq mois
mais c'est quand même hyper chez vous
parce qu'en fait vous vous ne connaissez
moi je vous connais pas c'est que moi je
vous ai pas dit ça pour vous donner un
peu une idée de ce que ça fait c'est
comme si vous arrivez à une convention
on nous fait fabien way comment tu sais
que je m'appelle fabien c'est écrit là
sur ta petite pancarte
ah oui ça va très bien ok merci beaucoup
je n'attends comment tu sais je
m'appelle jonathan j'ai pas de pancarte
je ne suis pas n'importe quel fabien je
suis fabien olicard mentalist donc bref
vous voyez ce feeling quand vous dis un
truc et on comprenait pas d'où la
personne le sait et ensuite vous dites
ah oui bah y'a un petit laps de temps où
c'est hyper chou et vinça les créateurs
ça nous arrive régulièrement
après ce qui est drôle c'est que souvent
quand je vous croise si par exemple vous
me suivez sur instagram ou à l'époque me
suivait sur snapped hâte
vous allez me le dire tout de suite dire
au fait je suis testory et tout j'adore
ça et en fait c'est marrant parce que
directement ça vous place à un autre
niveau de moi dans la carte de
communauté du coup j'imagine que je suis
un peu plus préparés à ce que vous me
sortir des trucs intime et où je sais
pas mais mais c'est marrant parce que
souvent vous ressentez ce besoin de me
le dire de me dire je fais partie du
crew pour en revenir à ce que je vous
disais au début avec le patois cyrus je
pense que pour une énorme majorité
d'entre vous à un moment ou un autre
je vais vous décevoir c'est sûr il ya
celles et ceux qui du coup arrêteront de
me suivre et à celles et ceux qui vont
continuer à me suivre parce que parfois
même avec les gens qu'on apprécie
on n'est pas d'accord ce concept de
relations parent social je trouve super
intéressant et c'était important pour
moi de vous en parlait déjà sur un truc
qui n'a rien à voir avec
avec moi directement c'est que bah je
trouve que ça nous rappelle aussi
pourquoi c'est important d'avoir une
vraie diversité dans les gens qu'on
regarde le au cinéma à la télévision
tout ça parce que c'est important on
projette des chaussures ces gens là et
donc c'est mieux si c'est représentatif
de la société dans laquelle on vit
et l'autre raison pour laquelle chose
c'est important d'en parler c'est juste
par rapport à nous en fait c'est ça
paraît bête mais dans une relation c'est
hyper important de se dire les choses
et voilà je trouve ça important que ce
soit dit que vous n'êtes pas mes amis
voilà qu on n'est pas amis en fait j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour vous j'espère
que vous en avez pour moi et je suis
extrêmement fier heureux de vous avoir à
cette place qui est la place de la
communauté c'est une place qui est très
particulière et très importante pour moi
c'est difficile à concevoir j'imagine
qu'on n'en a pas une mais vraiment c'est
une place à part qui encore une fois je
vous le dis est importante mais voilà
même en tant que joueur je pense que
c'est un truc dont il faut se rappeler
dans nos rapports avec les créateurs et
les créatrices
on n'est pas à leurs amis c'est pas
négatif parce que ça apporte quand même
une dimension sociale qui a un vrai
effet qui nous est vraiment dans la vie
et c'est qu'il nous apporte du soutien
et du support émotionnel c'est pas un
truc contre lequel on va lutter on va
pas l'empêcher de fait ça marche comme
ça mais je trouve ça important d'en être
pleinement conscients voilà le but de
cette vidéo c'est vraiment pas que ça va
être une distance entre vous et moi
c'est plus que on se regarde droit dans
les yeux qu'on dise ok c'est cool qu'on
se soit dit ce genre de choses on a une
relation saine
toi et moi je vous embrasse très fort
love vraiment pis ciao